good afternoon everybody thank you for
coming
Margaret and I are thrilled that you're
here and it's the second annual joint
Grand Rounds many years ago Margaret and
I talked about lots of opportunities to
really engage together around leadership
development research evidence-based
practice and this is a culmination of
some of those ideas that we talked about
when I interviewed Margaret for Dean and
so I'm delighted that the day is here I
just want to say how thrilled we are
with having Donna here and what an
influence she has had on so many of us
over the years many many staff in the
Yale New Haven Hospital organization
have either been her students have been
mentored by Donna or in some way
influenced by her experience with
research with policy with advanced
practice and clearly with nursing itself
I actually will be doing the interview
on behalf of Diane vorio who was called
away for the day she is sorely sorely
disappointed that she is not here to
participate in this work and I will read
her words so if I look like I am reading
from this document I am so I was
practicing before I came over with her
words and where the phrases might be so
if I stumble I apologize to Donna but
she's so good with this she'll pick it
up as we go
just one correction on your agenda at
342 350 it says the virginia henderson
award indeed it is not the Virginia
award is the Donna dears Awards so that
is a typo so without further ado from me
I'll turn it over to the Dean thank you
sue I have two great pleasures this
afternoon the first is to add my welcome
to Sue's to this annual joint nursing
Grand Rounds last year we heard Angela
Barron McBride be interviewed by Donna
so tables now turn donna gets to be the
interviewee or interview ye-yes as
opposed to the interview I do want to
say to kind of alluded to the fact that
this is one of many collaborations
between Yale New Haven Hospital and the
School of Nursing this being a major one
but also we had the opportunity this
past year to write a grant together it
didn't get funded but it was but you
know 80% of all grants don't get funded
but in any case the opportunity to work
together with the staff that sue put
together and a team of people from
around the state around the education of
advanced practice nurses nursing was
really a wonderful collaboration and
then there are many others involving
research at various levels and others
and so we feel very privileged to be a
partner in many of these endeavors
today's masterclass is likely to provide
each one of us with new perspectives on
Nursing and leadership the second
delight I have this afternoon is to
introduce my colleague my mentor my
friend Donna dears Donna is a graduate
of the University of Wyoming Yale
University School of Nursing and the
University of Technology in Sydney
Australia she is identified with the
emergence of clinical nursing research
methodologies having written the first
tech book textbook on that
object research in nursing practice two
copies of which remain in my office
she is also recognized for her work and
on the policy and politics of advanced
practice nursing her work with DRG based
information for hospital data systems
begun in Australia and carried out for
many years here at Yale New Haven has
informed clinical operational and
financial decision making not only in
Australia and here at Yale New Haven but
across the United States
she was Dean of the Yale University
School of Nursing from 1972 to 1985 I
note that I was a student then Donna
taught me my first ever research course
and that turned out reasonably well her
publications have appeared in all major
nursing journals in the United States
and in many journals in health services
in nursing across the United States
Australia and New Zealand focusing on
helping nurses to use information
technology and administrative data to
enhance nursing services she was editor
in what was then called image now called
the Journal of Nursing scholarship for
eight years and continues to serve as a
manuscript reviewer for a number of
professional journals a pop popular
public speaker
she also consults and teaches on writing
for publication her book speaking of
Nursing narratives of practice research
policy and the profession essays from
her her thoughts over the years one the
ajn Book of the Year award
in night in 2005 in 2010 she was named a
living legend by the American Academy of
Nursing and this past spring she
received an honorary Doctorate from the
University of Wyoming it is my honor to
introduce this wise woman cherish mentor
and devoted nurse for today's
masterclass
Thank You Margaret you can hear me okay
as Margaret said last year at this time
we had as our guest here Angela Baron
McBride another renowned leader and
Donna actually was the interviewer
Angela and referred to her new work
many of us have since purchased it the
growth and development of nurse leaders
and it was indeed memorable I went
online just before I came over and
googled it it's on YouTube so I was
reminded of how fine an event and
instructional it was for all of us as
well as fun and what a good interview
heard on it was at that time so here we
go
you know I am honored to be here she's
been a role model for so many of us
myself included and you know as a young
student I too used that research book
and I was very excited to come to this
organization and meet the Donna dear so
it's a pleasure to be here today that
has had a strong influence on young New
Haven Hospital I remember coming and
listening to her talk about data and
about some of the work that she had done
with our patient service managers at the
time around their masters projects
really looking at data and looking at
the complexity of nursing units and
really focusing at the level of that
unit based data to determine the
complexity in the mix of patients she
has been a leader in the develop of
development of what we call the nursing
data office in this organization and I
think it was a key to our magnet work
and actually her writing skills came to
the fore when we went through that
magnet journey Donna got stuck
viewing me for transformational
leadership trying to figure out how do
we bring that chapter together she kept
coming back and said this what you meant
so here we go
so we're focusing on the book called
speaking for nursing a narrative
practice research policy in the
profession
Linda akin the Claire Fagan leadership
professor of Nursing describes this book
as a must read for nursing's leaders and
for those who are interested in
understanding more about the uniqueness
of Nursing what moved you to write this
book well I'm sorry we're focusing on it
because it's out of print so sorry about
that I had the extraordinary opportunity
while I was a visiting professor in
Australia in Sydney at the University of
Technology Sydney to become aware of and
then to participate in a particularly
particular doctoral program there is an
option in Australia if there is in many
European countries and in New Zealand
for what they call a PhD by publication
which meant that I needed to take my
publications and make some kind of sense
of them and that's a whole lot harder
than you would think it would be
especially if they cover like 40 years
so I did that and I had some really
wonderful dissertation advisors because
of Judith Donahue and professor Jackie
crisp both of whom occupy positions that
we would call joint appointments here
there they are
appointments focused on developing
research in whatever institution they're
in jackie was it sydney kids hospital
judith was at st. george and they were
just wonderful they could not have been
more supportive more helpful i mean by
then i was old
and and kind of thought I knew what I
was doing and nobody was going to tell
me what they did and they were very
gracious about it and so I produced a
the manuscript on time you have to do
these things in a year and then it gets
sent out to a group of people that are
selected by the committee and by the
candidate and one of the people who
reviewed it was Linda akin another one
is one was Ellen mmm what is your last
name Ellen something who was the very
first professor of nursing in Australia
and the third was a woman who had been
head of the major nursing organization
Judy Lumbee and then as the candidates
you sit around and wait and they
approved the thing and so I went out
there and did the graduation ceremony
which was wonderful fun because the
graduation gown that you wear at UTS is
scarlet and it has a white satin sailor
collar and it's really quite elegant and
it has the very best hat in the world
graduation hats are uniformly terrible
this one is really really good and I was
happy about that but when I came back
home and read my dissertation again it
was very pedantic it was it had to be it
was anticipation that's what they are
and I thought I've had other things to
say about some of these matters that
haven't ever been published because I
gave a lot of speeches over the years
and I thought I wonder if I can make
something out of the unpublished
speeches over the years and so I
developed them into the four themes that
are in the book which are essentially
the same four themes that are in the
dissertation minus one I switched one
around
I and I made a proposal to the publisher
and the publisher liked it and so I
wrote it now it was already written you
understand so this is the easiest
possible way to do a book friends if you
have given a lot of speeches and you
have had the foresight to write them
down then you're in good shape so I
added some stuff I deleted some stuff I
wrote second thoughts to each one of the
sections and I picked some other things
that were never actually speeches but
we're things that I wish somebody had
asked me to talk about and put it
together in a book and I was astonished
and how well it went
it was published in 2004 so it's eight
years old and copyrights run out and
seven that's why it's not for print
anymore and I got all kinds of nice
feedback from people one of the things I
did in the book that was surely unusual
for me but unusual apparently and the
way these kind of books happen is I
wrote a fair bit about myself personally
and my family and where I was at the
point in time where one of the chapters
happened one of the speeches happened
and I got more feedback on that than I
ever got on the serious content so be it
I think I'll stop there and you can go
on to your next I'll try or if it wasn't
you I was looking to chapter 2 here so I
can elaborate one thing because I don't
think it's probably going to come up
naturally in this conversation I in the
in the intro to the thing I wrote a
little piece about being from Wyoming
and I am from Wyoming and as a matter of
fact I'm going to move back to Wyoming
and not far distant future to the same
town that I grew up in it was a
wonderful place to grow up
Wyoming is very independent it's
actually when I went to Australia
I realized that one of the things that
made me fall totally in love with it on
the first trip was it's a lot like
Wyoming it's bold and it's brash and
it's colorful and it's beautiful but the
story behind the story which isn't in
the book is why Wyoming and the story
there is about two strong women my
grandmother's one of my grandmother's
who was a Welsh woman her name was mezzo
kerry
Courtney deers poor woman was had
tuberculosis shortly after she and my
grandfather married well their children
were like five six seven and the thing
you did was TB in those days they were
they lived in Nebraska was to move to
the mountains and it happened that the
town that they moved to the town I'm
going back to is at the foothills of the
nearest mountains that's why she ended
up there and eventually worked in a dry
goods store and my grandfather worked a
number of jobs he was trained as an
accountant I don't think I've ever told
Steve alligretto that I must do that my
other grandmother Ella Myrtle and then
she had two husbands so she has two
different last names she was also from
Nebraska and she married at 17 after
following her husband-to-be who was a
minor league baseball player around on
the circuit she was a groupie if you
ever knew my grandmother in her older
years where she was a staunch Methodist
lady you would never believe that but
it's a true story
her husband the baseball player
unfortunately died in the flu epidemic
in 1918 and left her with two small
children my mother who's the oldest and
my and my late uncle and she needed to
do something and it was the beginning of
the depression it was not a good time
altogether but her sister and her
husband and the sisters husband had
located a place in south western Wyoming
which is truly the armpit of the
universe it's a town called WOM Sutter
and it needs to disappear it's just not
a good place and her sister Ida invited
her to come out and homestead with them
on the prairies and with the
rattlesnakes and so she did and in the
homesteading game you got a Shack a
tarpaper Shack essentially you did
whatever you did to provide yourself at
the bathroom
and my mother recalled and was fond of
telling me that she and my uncle would
carry wakes to school to fend off the
rattlesnakes she was not able to prove
up which is what they called it then on
the homestead meaning to improve the
property so much that it would become
her own and she took a job as a waitress
in the in the cafe that served the
railroad that came through warm center
nothing else came through and she met
there her second husband Ray Ball who
was a work on the railroad and he
married her and they had two more
children such that my aunt who is the
youngest of the four of them is only six
years older than I am
so she's an almost sister and her
daughter is an almost sister and we have
a interesting little trio there they
moved to Sheridan the same town that my
other grandmother had moved to and
eventually my mother and
her my father met and fell in love and
married and you would think that with
such a nice sort of connection there in
a small town the two grandparents
meeting my grandfather my father's
father and the grand mother my mother's
mother would get together they were both
widows they called each other mr. dears
and mrs. ball to the end of their lives
they were simply two different different
people my grandfather was very Teutonic
he was very tall he was six foot eight
and he had acromegaly there's a big
undershot doll my grandmother was after
actually a very tall - and had they ever
danced but she was Methodist you
understand dance they would have looked
quite good together but it was kind of a
local story that mr. dears and mrs. ball
kind of never got cotton to each other
as it were okay
yeah I gotta fix this whole thing now
sorry sue
all right all right we're gonna go back
to my notes all right in the forward
diana Mason states that Donna dears has
thrown the mantle of leadership out to
all nurses that we may follow her lead
in thinking about advocating for and
speaking of Nursing and all of its
glorious complexity at the end of the
forward she notes that public speaking
as a leader is not always easy and
certainly has not been easy for her
being yourself
she then quotes Donna I think of myself
is actually quite quiet timid and
chicken but with the responsibility to
use a leadership position or a role in
the service of the dancing nursing I'm
morph into a Tyrannosaurus Rex tell us
about those times can you give us some
examples of when you morphed into a
Tyrannosaurus Rex and what advice might
you have for the rest of us when we're
timid quiet and or chicken find a cause
next question
no seriously I mean I discovered early
on that I'm really not a very good nurse
clinically I'm just not it's just not me
but I find nursing remarkably
fascinating and so over the years
without particularly planning it this
way I've taken up nursing's cause in
various venues the public speaking thing
did actually scare me witless when I was
young and hadn't done a lot of it you
get better over time or with the wonders
of modern chemistry twenty-five
milligrams of inderal work
but I remember one of the first great
big speeches I ever did and I had this
wonderful outfit it was a two-piece
white knit dress white is the operative
word here and I was this was somewhere
in Kansas and I was in the second floor
of a motel and the meeting rooms were on
a lower level and I got to at the top of
the stairs to go down at the meeting
room so my knees were shaking so bad I
couldn't walk down those stairs without
falling all the way and I thought oh god
I'm gonna have to sit down and you know
do the thing so I walked around knowing
that I was fairly visible in this white
dress and found a back stair and was
able to without anybody watching get
down the stairs but it was awful in
those early days you learn after a while
to how to deal with an audience you
learn that from teaching actually but
you learn how to deal with an audience
and and after a while after having
adopted nursing as a cause then and
having done a couple of iterations of
trouble making speeches you get asked to
do more iteration some trouble making
speech speeches because Nursing is so
complicated and it's so controversial to
people out there it's not controversial
to us we know what it is we know what
we're doing
we think it's by and large pretty good
but there are a lot of people out there
who are stuck in 1928 visions of Nursing
and I that was my cause I was going to
try to fix that among other things
turning into Tyrannosaurus Rex the fruit
I've done it a number of times
including once here quite famously but
we won't go there one time I do remember
is I was asked at the last minute to
cover for a woman named Ingham in
Bournemouth who was a distinguished
nursing leader and was working with a
Robert Wood Johnson Foundation on what
was then called primary care nursing and
Inga was supposed to be the keynote
speaker at there at the Johnson
Foundation's annual conference on
primary care and she could not do it
because she was on the board of the
Holocaust Museum she being a Holocaust
survivor in Washington and they were
opening the museum that weekend so she
couldn't do it and she called me and
asked me to do this and I thought oh
come on me and then I thought hmm and so
I did it and the paper is published it's
in the ajn and I don't know 19 something
worthy but seated in front of me were a
whole lot of distinguished people
including Clair Fagan Linda Aiken who
was then working for the Johnson
Foundation as their senior clinical
person and the whole staff of the
Johnson Foundation who at the time were
all physicians and all very physician
oriented and many of us in nursing were
very unhappy with the Johnson Foundation
in those years because they were
dedicated to throwing money at
physicians and couldn't see nurses
altogether and so in the middle of this
speech I essentially said you do realize
of course that primary care is and
always has been nursing and you could
have heard a pin drop
and when Dakin remembers that to this
day and she twits me about it from time
to time so does Claire but it's true we
were the first people to be out there in
the neighborhoods walking across the
roofs in Manhattan to deliver primary
care to the immigrant populations nurse
midwives have been there forever and
primary care as a visiting nursing and
related efforts now there's a lot of
them has always been nursing and by and
large I didn't say it then but by and
large physicians aren't really very
interested in the first contact patients
who are unselected and sick and sorting
that out is really not kind of what they
like to do so I think that speech to the
extent it got out and it did get out
through the publication began to turn
the dialogue maybe in advanced practice
nursing because to take on the Robert
Wood Johnson Foundation in public was
it's sort of brave I suppose i hain't
care what I have to lose we did we'd
applied to the Johnson Foundation for
money and been turned down many many
times so it wasn't gonna ruin me there
well given what you just said where do
you think it's gonna go where do you
think Nursing is gonna go what are the
possibilities these abilities are
totally endless absolutely and
completely endless we can go any place
we want to go so long as we are educated
and free to do it and I think the IOM
report that came out now two years ago
is a perfect roadmap for how to do that
it has because the IOM report was not
written by nurses
the committee was chaired by under
co-chaired by a nurse but the committee
itself was made up of a lot of other
people besides nurses and so what it
challenged us to do is to fix some of
our eternal problems especially our
nursing education ladder which isn't and
it nailed head-on the problems that
advanced practice nurses have moving
from state to state because the laws are
so screwed up state to state and it it
gave us a place to go so that's that's
one bit of evidence for where I think
Nursing is going the other bit is I'm
just now totally fascinated by what's
appearing in the nursing journals in
quality and safety especially in quality
and safety and in operations management
and I sorry Margaret but not so much in
research some some of it yes but my
interest has shifted away from clinical
nursing research to systems research
operations and so on you people are
doing the most amazing stuff out there
and it comes out of your understanding
of practice and by that I mean not only
how to take care of patients you are
wonderfully trained and how to do that
and how to manage the equipment and I
see Marie out there she took me to her
sick you one day and they were decanting
a patient from the operating room and
she had at least seven tubes in her god
knows what else that she was attached
and I thought you people do astonishing
work clinically but where you really do
astonishing work is in understanding how
things work and that's operation do you
understand how a nursing unit works you
understand how to manage obstreperous
physicians if you need to you understand
how to manage patients whose families
speak no English and who are romeny
gypsies it's just amazing stuff
and nobody knows about it but us and so
toward the end of my career here I'm
trying to figure out how to make nursing
more visible to the lay community who is
everybody but us and so that means the
media means newspapers it means
television I actually like Nurse Jackie
by the way and so I've begun to make
some connections with there's a
professional organization of healthcare
journalist and a Diana Mason is part of
that group and and we're plotting things
that could be done with that group
because healthcare journalists don't
understand Nursing all together as you
well know from reading the newspapers
actually one of the people who
understands Nursing the best is at Olga
Wandy the physician the surgeon from
Mass General Deaconess that whole thing
of their partners and the prolific New
Yorker writer he and he gets it or he
gets most budget he's got a wonderful
essay out there about following a home
care hospice nurse around and
understanding in a way he had never
understood before what that work was
like and why it mattered you've wound
every question on this oh sorry to the
audience I found a couple of in here
interesting that you answered most of
what Diane had on this pieces of paper
as questions the last one was talk about
why publish write about nursing and
clearly you answered that well but there
are two last questions that she has here
and I'm gonna read them one is vision
doesn't necessarily make a leader but a
leader without a vision isn't what's
written on leadership
today about heroes what leaders have
inspired you and who are your heroes
well I've had so many opportunities to
have working relationships and
friendships and sponsorships of
extraordinary nurses I have that there's
no top I don't want to name the top 10
or top 20 or the top 49 among the people
that I value or have valued because they
aren't all with us anymore
our Engelberg mouse was an extraordinary
woman who's particularly whose
particular capacity
I always thought fueled by her Holocaust
survivor shift was to always keep the
humanity of the issue whatever it was we
were dealing with at the center we
weren't just about making decisions we
were about making the right decisions
Rosella short felt who was a long term
Dean of the Case Western Reserve School
of Nursing in Cleveland took me under
her wing when I was a brand-new Dean she
invited me into her house and for one
evening she showed me what she does in
the evening you're better at this bar
grit then she was but she read her mail
and she went through it with me piece by
piece
this one I will do this with this one I
will do this with this one I'm gonna
throw away this one ooh this one's
trouble here's what I'm thinking about
it and she warned me about the things
that she thought were the hardest that
she had ever had to deal with as a Dean
and the very hardest was having a
student who was raped as she did and
eventually as I did we have it's our
Edith Patton Lewis who none of you will
have heard of was the long term editor
actually of all of the three big
Adrienne Company journals ajn nursing
outlook and Nursing Research
she was a wild woman a wild character
she'd come to nursing through the gettin
kind of a route she'd been a college
graduate from Smith and then went into
nursing at Columbia which had the only
program at the time and she was very
very fond of words as am i and so we had
great conversation she also smoked like
a chimney which eventually killed her
but not till she was 94 she was a
remarkable woman and she taught me
particularly the value of being an
activist editor that is one of the
things that's really fun about being an
editor is that you you get to see the
manuscripts before they're published so
you can see what people are thinking out
there and with a little clever
positioning of articles and stuff like
that you can foster something and we did
that image on a couple of times she also
taught me how to write editorials
editorial writing is a craft that you
simply have to learn you have to have
one and only one idea you it has to be
crisp and it has to be pithy and I know
nobody in nursing who is writing those
kind of editors any more editorials
anymore I tried to perfect that when I
was editor of image and I got a lot of
feedback that I did I also got fired by
Sigma Theta top
others Linda akin is truly astonishing
her she has many many gifts as a
researcher but what she's really really
good at is making the connection between
her research which has all to do with
interesting resources and patient
outcomes making the connection between
that and the policy issues that are
relevant right now and somebody just
sent me today her very newest article
which is in Health Services Research
where she and her team have looked at
mortality in cardiac surgery patients
know it's in triple-a triple-a patients
which are cardiac surgery patient and
she finds that increased nursing
staffing predicts lower mortality but
that staffing up in a poorly organized
or managed Hospital does not improve
mortality and that distinction is going
to be really really important as we move
forward I have any number of other
people Robert Leonard who is not a nurse
but was very important to me when I
first graduated from the master's
program at Yale and began to teach I
took over his course having just taken
his course he by the way is in Las Vegas
this weekend I had a an email from him
at the World Poker Championship and he's
quite good there are so many people who
have influenced me as friends as
colleagues as sponsors as people who
give you a pushing you know shove you
out the door and say go go for it as a
matter of fact Mike Loftus has done that
several times to me when I worked in the
hospital
Ghana you go do it - Steve alligretto
I would be remiss by trying to name
others because there's so many and I
don't want to leave anybody out so go to
your next question please
well I've actually heard you respond to
this
but elaborate a bit the question is
knowing what I know now would I do it
again in a New York minute I fell into
nursing just because I fell under
nursing um the person who inspired me
was the mother of some friends of mine
who lived up the street in this little
town in Wyoming and she was the
supervisor at the little Hospital which
is still there 88 beds and she always
wore white and wore the cap and wore the
white stockings and wore the shoes and
she was just magnificent and now I'm
talking about the 1940s and 50s
we're in the big disease that we worried
about and shared in Wyoming in the
summer it was polio they shut down the
local swimming pool their you know
friends were being stricken including my
very best friend Beth who came down with
polio and Georgia the nurse nursed them
and when she would come home from her
shift in the afternoon the first thing
she did before she went in the house was
take off her uniform and hang it on the
clothesline and that conveyed something
to me about professionalism other than
that had I not been a nurse I would have
been a journalist because I do so love
to write but I'm too timid I'm too shy
to be the kind of journalist I'd like to
be that is to say an investigative
journalism I can't get in your face and
say did you really pass that information
along did the Soviets
and what I found in nursing is a way to
put those two together and it's been
absolutely the thing to do for me
nursing has fit me not as a clinical
nurse don't ask me to nurse you
clinically very dangerous but as a group
of people to hang out with as a group of
issues to work on God the issues in
nursing are so interesting yes I would
do it over again and as a matter of fact
I wish I could because knowing what I
know now I would do it better and faster
and more efficiently and perhaps things
would move a little faster but I have
realized that I have done what I can I
will continue to do what I can I will
continue to write for sure and I'm
extraordinarily satisfied with the
career I've had I've had opportunities
that are just incredible to travel to
get to know people in different
disciplines to find nursing is very much
the same from country to country to
country the issues are the same it's
just that these people figured out a way
to do it and these people haven't the
I'm just drifting off there with a
little international story that I don't
really have to tell it's in nursing if
you want to take advantage of it gives
you an opportunity to do all kinds of
interesting things from volunteering in
Botswana as alumna of the School of
Nursing has recently done with her
husband if she did not volunteer as a
nurse because she's not licensed in but
about SWANA but she volunteered as a
health education teacher and her husband
who is a psychiatrist couldn't practice
that either but he volunteered as
something else I forgotten exactly what
it was
and she was just written up in the
yellow my magazine she and her husband
for for this effort which they took they
were there for two years they took that
long I know a nurse in Australia a nurse
practitioner who is the only health care
person for four months of the year on a
little tiny island off the north coast
of Australia where the major industry is
shrimp fishing and she goes out with the
shrimp Fisher persons and their families
and she does that for four months of the
year and she's the only health care
person so she told me you know her I
said what's your scope of practice
she said she has had recently taken care
of the pilot of the plane that was
supposed to fly her off this I don't
think who collapsed with a heart attack
as he was loading her suitcase into the
back of the plane she did a lot of
getting fish hooks out of people's
fingers she did labor and delivery and
delivered babies she did everything she
was the only health care person and I
said wasn't that kind of lonesome and
she said no she had a phone connection
to somebody back at the base hospital
and she was too busy anyway and it was
way too interesting and too much fun I
know I know so many interesting nurses
who do so many interesting things but
this might be the way to wind this up I
know the three nurses who took care of
my mother at home they were a CNA an LPN
and an RN and they kept her laughing to
the extent she had any breath to laugh
and they kept she and my father
functioning until they no longer could
simply do that and they were absolutely
magnificent to me when I needed to be
called and to fly immediately across the
country to take care of
I have one final questions my question
as I listened your answers have been so
eloquent but while you talked about why
nursing my right about nursing and an
unbelievably rich career you never
mentioned why you got so interested in
data and mining the data what drove you
there well when I ended the the deanship
at Yale after twelve and a half years I
was offered the opportunity to work with
the DRG guys the guys who invented Dr
jeez at Yale through John Thompson who
was a professor in the School of Public
Health and and who was a nurse and
through those two hats I I knew and he
invited me onto the research team which
was then doing what became the last of
the studies that were done here and it
was about could we use available
administrative data to wait WEEI ght
wait DRGs by measures of Nursing
intensity and I I was thinking about
this the other day when I was thinking
about what you might ask me and I think
the reason John asked me to join the
club as it were is because by then I
knew a lot of the people in Washington
and I think he thought I could be the
spokesperson for this effort which you
know a lot of people never knew that
John was a nurse so they thought that
all his DRG nonsense was done by you
know them operations researchers and it
really wasn't and so I joined the team
and talked about a learning curve I was
really really truly a learning curve but
when I got to see the data that they
were working with and got to understand
how the data got in there and got to
understand what the data were it was a
cause man because nobody to this day
nobody hardly except you around here and
I'm serious about that know what's in
the data and how it can speak to nursing
I have these conversations all the time
I just had a conversation when somebody
who's a nurse at mass at Partners who
was trying to do something with her
units information to try to figure out
how they can be a little better and she
had no idea what was in her data set
even though she fills out the
information forms every bloody day and
so I got really intrigued with that and
then along about the same time I met
Steve allegretto who is an amazing
person he was a student of mine in the
School of Public Health he likes to tell
the story about how I flunked him one of
his early papers and it's true it was
not a good paper but he pinned me down
after class one time and said you know
we really need to capture nursing at
yellow heaven in a way that we haven't
before and by then I was deep enough
into this project that I knew about
waiting dear geez and would you like to
talk with me a little bit more about how
we could maybe do that and I said sure
and so we had another conversation he
hired me on the spot like without
references or anything and then I had
the brilliance to hire Janice bozo who
was a student of mine in the School of
Nursing and whose career was headed in a
whole other direction and we together
conducted great enormous study with a
committee of people that Sue had
appointed and we waited DRGs
by expert estimates of nursing care
requirements and it was tedious as hell
but it was really a lot of fun because
those nurses got to understand what was
inside the data too and it started to
spread and and God knows Janice and I
got to understand the difference among
nursing units how nursing units differ
from one another in case-mix but also in
all kinds of other ways and I got very
intrigued with the notion that Sue was
then talking about
about nurse managers being the CEOs of
their unit every nursing unit is a
business it's a little-bitty
or bigger business depending on what it
is and it must be managed not only as a
business but as a production we produce
patient care and we need to have that
recognized in the systems that monitor
us including the financial assistance
and I learned a whole lot from Steve and
from Charlie here who were part of the
early days of what we called rims then
and I guess you still call it rims which
is all about using the yellow havens
existing clinical operational and
financial data to make decisions and
that sounds like such a simple
proposition let's use some data well it
isn't and the development that you guys
have done here is just phenomenal
across the country in actually using
data to make planning decisions to make
quality decisions to make hiring
decisions particularly of physicians to
redistribute beds around and what I fell
in love with the most was to understand
nursing units
I think nursing units are so interesting
because there's so much going on all the
time and it's all balls in the air and
the nurses have to figure out how to do
that not only so that nobody dies but so
that people are happy working there and
so that patients get out of the hospital
as soon as possible and so that's how I
sort of fell into data and then once in
it couldn't possibly leave it because it
was just so much fun Thank You Donna I
think that influence today is still
enormous Lee felt and while you talked
about you know what data does one thing
you left out was you know the ability
your work gave us language
to secure resources in a resource
strapped environment and I cannot tell
you how powerful that has been because
Donna was able to give us the structure
to prove not only the influence of
volume on a unit but the complexity of
the patience and and how that then
yielded in a mathematical type of way
the need for nursing resources inclusive
leadership resources as well as at the
caregiver level so your influence will
be felt is felt and will be felt for
many many many years to come
and I think those of you that don't know
Donna well doesn't know maybe the work
that you have done you feel that
influence I can tell you every day
because she gave us the ability to
articulate what that looks like in a way
that Steve Allegretto who has an
unending draw of FTEs I knew it I knew
when you said he hired you on the spot
he's got some draw of FTEs I'm going
back and finding them but how powerful
that language is when you have to
compete for resources so your impact
will be felt for many many many many
years it's a true legacy that I think
you have left so I thank you very much
so we do have microphones strategically
placed and hopefully some of you will
take this opportunity to ask Donna some
questions
hi Donna my name is Judy Hahn and I work
with a lot of nursing students and a lot
of nurses who are struggling to write
and I thought maybe with your years of
experience as a faculty member and a
writer yourself if you could offer us
any suggestions as far as how to
encourage people to get that confidence
to have their voice heard and become
writers I don't mean this comment to be
flip all together but it is the essence
of it Paul Simon has a song in which one
of the lines is want to be a writer
don't know where or when find a quiet
place and grab a humble pen but you
first got to have an idea
and that converting an idea into
something that might be written whether
it ever ends up being published or not
it's harder than you think
I analyzed for the first 20 minutes of a
speech I have to write or an article I
have to start because it just won't and
it still happens I had to do something
last week and I thought oh I'm old now
can I get over this no you don't get
over the trick is to figure out two
things one is who's your audience who do
you want to convince or whose ideas do
you want to change or whatever who's
your audience and the other is what's
your story what is this about what is
this article about and that I'm Margaret
can truly attest that that happens for
experienced researchers as well how do
we want to frame this so that it affects
whatever it is that you you want to
affect from there on it's those two
things on it's a matter of I think
personal style
some people just sit down and write and
then throw out the pieces of paper when
it's not going where you want it to go I
can't bare throwing away
some people want to talk it out with
somebody and that's always a good
strategy some people write it out as
fast and furiously as they can and then
put it in a box somewhere and sit on it
for six weeks and then come back and see
whether it still makes sense some people
take a writing course I mean a creative
writing course not just a teal writing
course but a creative writing course
because the people who do that have all
kind of tricks for you know how to get
started how to keep going how to develop
the thoughts how to develop the
characters if you're writing fiction
whatever it's it's harder than it looks
but it's also easier than it looks
because after that first 20 minutes
you're on a roll
hi my name is Heather I'm a service line
educator in Madison when you talk about
operations management on the unit that's
exactly what happens I'm sure everyone
agrees and I never really thought about
it before you mentioned it today but
it's not something that's taught in
undergraduate education and I think that
it's definitely something that nursing
students should be exposed to so do you
think there's a way that we could get
that into the curriculum somehow well
sure I've done any number of
presentations that quinnipiac any
undergraduate curriculum I don't know
that that's the place to put it because
undergraduates are so scared and they've
got so much to learn and cram in their
heads and they get moved every six weeks
from somewhere to somewhere else I think
maybe if you had a final year kind of a
capstone seminar free discussion thing
you could probably do something
interesting with the operations
management content we teach it at ysn in
the nursing management policy and
leadership course and we will teach it
in the DNP as well and I need to put in
a plug for those two programs which we
are recruiting for as we speak
the content itself is not hard and
nurses understand it in their bones
because you have to live with it every
day
you just need a language as sue talked
about you need a language for how to
talk about that and it's it's actually
not very hard and there are theories out
there theories and operations management
theories and organizational behavior
there is an organizational diagnosis
that are just incredibly powerful and
and terrifically useful if you know
there's theories out there and if you
know how to put them into helping to
understand your working environment life
Donna
Francine hi I have a question as far as
and I wanted to thank you publicly
because you have done a lot for us here
at Yale New Haven I will say that and
Sue has summarized helping us talk to
Steve and Charlie has been an exciting
endeavor and trying to get people to
understand operations but one of the
things you had mentioned in your book
was around that Nursing is not an
oppressed group but the rest of the
world hasn't caught up how do you think
about that now I mean do you think the
world is catching up because I still
think there's that oppression that
sometimes you hear from nurses ah but
that's the distinction Francie you don't
hear it from the outside world they have
no idea whether we're oppressed or not
they don't care
we think of ourselves as oppressed and
or not and and we need to simply get
over behaving like that now we're
getting way better at that way better at
that the public media are not
particularly getting better but there
are serious efforts being mounted the
most serious of which that I know is at
UCLA where Courtney Leiter who's the
Dean there has orchestrated now two
national conferences on Nursing in the
media in
solving the media not just ourselves
saying oh ho ain't it awful how they
portray us involving the media and
involving people who analyze the media
they're one of the conference's the
first one is published in a special
issue of Nursing outlook and I recommend
it to anybody it's like the September
October issue of Nursing outlook has a
special supplement I recommend everybody
read it because it lifted me completely
off my chair when I was reading it at
home at my dining room table it's full
of insight about why we might feel
oppressed by it by the media and it's
full of activities that people have done
to improve things did you know for
example that the American Medical
Association had a contract for a very
long time that they had script approval
for dr. Kildare and Ben Casey
no wonder they came out the way they did
and there's still some of that going on
although it's a whole lot less the AMA
has kind of lost some speed there
there's still some of that going on with
house and the other programs I don't
even know their names I don't watch them
what is distinctive about what this guy
who analyzes this stuff says it's
distinctive about it Nurse Jackie is it
its origins aren't in the previous nurse
shows and China Beach and all of the
ones that came before their origins are
in The Sopranos
because Edie Falco played mrs. soprano
and so that that the tone of Nurse
Jackie is straight out of The Sopranos
and it sort of helps to understand that
and maybe to say that you know they
portray her her social life and her
family life as kind of dysfunctional but
they portray her nursing life as right
on target hi I'm Jacqueline I'm a new
nurse here at Yale New Haven Hospital
and actually a new nurse raise your hand
or something I can't tell where you are
there thank you
I'm feeling at Yale New Haven as if we
are in an era where we are in the
business of providing care and I came
from a business background I'm wondering
how you feel about that within the
nursing schools it's certainly the one
to which I went did not provide that
kind of background
or education what do you think I'm not
sure I get the point of view question
are you saying we should teach business
and there's instable so that people will
realize what they're going into yes well
it would be the same response to the the
other woman who wants us to teach
operations management there's no room in
the curriculum because for undergraduate
students now for masters programs
absolutely we should be doing and surely
for DNP programs but for undergraduate
programs they're not there those
students tell me if I'm wrong I just
don't think they can comprehend that
they're having so much stuffed in their
heads about how to not only do the
clinical work but manage to survive on
the unit with all the complexities that
go on on a unit I just don't think
they're there
let me ask her before you leave her
Ellen have you found your business
background helpful to you as a new nurse
yeah
go
I don't have a good answer other than
the one I'm just just given perhaps I'm
making this up on the spot but
Northeastern University used to have and
I'm not sure they still do perhaps
there's someone in the audience who
knows northeastern used to have this
really wonderful undergraduate nursing
program where students did either six
months or a year of basic nursing
education and then they went to work
with no seminars there anything for a
period of time I don't remember how long
it was and then they went back and did
more nursing and then they went to work
and it would be in those going to work
times where you could accomplish and and
the curtain was five five years long it
would be in those work periods where I
think you could do some interesting
stuff with business and with business
concepts and with operations research
operations concept
I saw her in the microphone to you so I
don't where you are
hi I'm Ian who is a registered nurse in
China I have a question that do you
think whether the nurse manager should
should have our nursing background with
our plenty of clean condos experience
let me make sure I understood your
question whether the nurse manager
should be a nurse yes would be the short
answer the business is nursing the
business were in is nursing and much as
I love my interdisciplinary colleagues
they don't get it get it in the depth
you need to manage it now I will tell
you a international story that will I
hope provide some evidence for that in
the mid 1990s Barbara where are you
Barbara because New Zealand went through
absolutely punishing health reforms in
order to shore up their the economics of
the country which had fallen on very bad
times and one of the strategies that
they used to accomplish this magnificent
effort was what they called
managerialism which is comes out of the
University of Chicago and is a theory
that says that any manager can manage
anything and so they removed the head
nurse positions and all senior positions
over the head nurse positions from all
hospitals furthermore they did it on a
Friday and dismissed these people with a
they don't do pink slips they do brown
slips but the brown slips and the people
who came back and they came back the
nurses who were not dismissed came back
on the Monday
and discovered that the new manager who
could have come from telecommunications
he could have come from the brewery
brewery industry he could have come from
anywhere but not he was not a nurse and
he wasn't a doctor either which would
have been maybe better but not much
discovered that his first task was
putting together a schedule because a
nursing unit doesn't close down at 5:00
o'clock in the afternoon and it was
complete chaos until somebody because
all the nurse managers had gone they've
gone away
there was nobody did tell him what to do
so he suddenly had to learn very fast
that you have to develop a 24-hour
schedule it's a 24-hour business those
people lasted about six months and they
began to fill them back in with nurses
meanwhile the nurses the nursing
leadership in New Zealand was decimated
many people migrated immigrated
permanently to Australia and it has left
the New Zealand healthcare delivery
system in the most terrible situation
Barbara McCluskey was sitting next to
Janice has done a couple of studies
where we have looked at data existing
data not to the nursing unit level but
to the hospital level and demonstrated
that where nursing resources are cut
measures of patient of negative patient
outcomes go up we've published them
twice
they've been circulated widely in New
Zealand one of our co-authors who is a
New Zealand professor of Nursing has
done a podcast for their local radio and
nobody pays any attention
why because Nursing is not a revenue
center
nursing doesn't bring any money into the
hospital but what is the hospital for if
not for nursing you could do a surgery
on the kitchen table if you felt like it
you can clearly do psychiatric stuff in
an office you can take people's blood
pressures and you can administer IVs at
home what you need a hospital for for
nursing 24 hour nursing now how do we
turn nursing into a revenue Center you
don't want me to do that lecture even
though it's not very long because it's a
piece of cake you just have to get your
finance department to understand how to
do it one more question if you are
director of hospital which one would you
prefer to choose to the to be the
nursing manager one is our younger nurse
with a high level of background and
heather has done a lot of research and
another one is our older nurse who or
who is who has a plentiful of clinical
nursing experience well I'd like to take
the best of both of them I mean that
that's an unanswerable question actually
because you want someone who understands
business who understands operations
stuff like that and that may well be a
younger person just because of the age
we're in and you want someone who really
understands the work in his or her bones
and if you can stick them together you
got your candidate I was just gonna make
it cut
I just wanted to make a comment before
he had mentioned about north eastern
university I went to Drexel University
and we also had a similar program where
we went
a total of 18-month work experience it
was a five-year program and I do agree
that like having a business perspective
might benefit and as well as understand
the operational systems I know I had
taken the leadership course I'm not
really sure what I learned in that
course but maybe they can incorporate
those two subjects in that of course but
I just wanted to say that having had
that five years experiences I think
useful my education knowing where I want
to go with my nursing career so thank
you for that we have time for like one
more question whatever you want
hi John it's Kerry got made here hi hi
how are you so great to see you and
patient safety coordinator in the
Department of Medicine I'm thrilled to
hear you say that safety and quality is
where it's at in research so we've got
to get cracking and do some writing on
that I guess my question is about
interdisciplinary education can you talk
a little bit about the opportunities for
physicians and nurses and pharmacists
occupational therapists all of us to
start to learn together to foster
interdisciplinary work that we do in the
clinical setting well this is gonna be a
fairly uninformed opinion because I
haven't given this one a lot of thought
but I surely we ought to have people who
are going to be caring for the same
patients together in the same room long
before they hit their first patient
partly to understand each other's
discipline and what each watch what each
discipline brings to the table and but
and here's the big button until our own
mindset changes and the mindset of
medical education and the mindset of
pharmacy education and whoever else we
want to throw in the pot until all of
those change and by mindset I don't mean
the content the you know anatomy
physiology what's it what sort what is
what's it it's what you do with the
content and so long as there is still a
notion that healthcare is mainly
medicine I don't think the hopes for
interdisciplinary education are really
terribly well founded now as you know
there is a lot of focus on
interdisciplinary education by funding
agencies and foundations and so on and I
will be interested to read what those
reports say when they've evaluated
whatever their projects were because I'm
really
really kind of cautious about thinking
that that's gonna solve the world's
problems I really don't think so it
doesn't mean we shouldn't try a
follow-up question so you talked about
mindset so how is it
I'm a very rubber hits the road let's
get moving let's do something how do you
change people's mindsets it's panel
discussions it's writing its advocacy
what do you have any ideas about that
well I don't know that you can do it
while they're students see that's the
tricky bit it's like the response to the
the people were here about can you teach
business and operations at the
undergraduate level and you heard what I
said about that I'm not sure you can
teach that kind of interdisciplinary
collaboration at the medical student
level now see we've got this funny thing
in health care education where we
educate our young at the baccalaureate
level they educate their young at what
is essentially the Masters level only
they call it a doctor pharmacy is has
now moved in that direction as well and
simply the difference in the age of
physician undergraduate students which
is where you'd want to start planting
the seeds and those in the other
disciplines is a handicap I think
because like nursing students who have
to stop with the stuff in their heads
while they're learning not to kill
somebody medical students are under an
even more punishing schedule you know
what a medical school curriculum looks
like it's really punishing and they get
it in little tiny drops like they get a
week on this and a week on that and a
week on that and maybe a couple of
observations in in the middle and that's
not conducive to thinking about the
patient that's behind the symptom or the
colleagues that you might need to deal
with to help the patient get to where
the patient needs to go I just think
there's a naivete
about pushing interdisciplinary
education without thinking you know how
old are the students going to be how
punishing is the curriculum gonna be you
know how can we stick this in somewhere
now there's some stuff that I think you
can teach and we're doing it too Anatomy
for example there's not a whole lot of
difference between what nursing students
need to know about that what medical
students need to know about that and it
might even be a good place to start and
so we're doing that when you start
getting to other areas I don't know
about that okay Kari
I appreciate your insight
I guess we're talking about a cultural
change that's way beyond the classroom
so we will continue this adventure thank
you
I want to thank Don I think this was
fabulous thank you
at this time we are going to award the
first ever Donna dears speaking of
Nursing Awards so it is with great joy
that I am here with Donna who is my
mentor to talk about these awards that
were created based on her book speaking
of Nursing the purpose of this award is
to provide a forum for nurses with a
passion for the profession to use
narratives or data as a mean of
demonstrating how their practice aligns
with Donna's definition of Nursing and
makes nursing visible locally regionally
and nationally nurses at all levels were
eligible this year all recipients were
nominated in the category of data
nursing and hospital operations the
criteria included demonstration of the
use of data by nurses that improves
hospital operations and our processes of
care resulting in positive outcomes for
patients staff the hospital the nursing
profession health policy in alignment
with Donna's definition which is Nursing
is two things the care of the sick or
the potentially sick and the tending of
the entire environment in which care
happens with that we would like to move
to the presentation of the awards I will
announce the committee selections with a
very brief outline of the rationale or
project and ask that the recipients join
us on stage as I call your name this
year we are pleased to present three
outstanding individuals with Adana dear
speaking of Nursing award they are Diane
Collins Diane created the data divin
quality and safety programs in the heart
and vascular service line most recently
using real-time data to reduce LVAD
driveline infections Diane is passionate
about data driving safer practice Lori
Hubbard
Loree through the yhh magnet journey
integrated data into the direct care
setting to quote a young New Haven
magnet ambassador Laurie's proficiency
was apparent to all who participated in
the overwhelming magnet process
Teresa Highland utilized data in the
women's and children's service line to
obtain specialized assistance for
newborn emergencies
Teresa analyzed data regarding emergency
call records and standardized the
nomenclature for the emergency response
in neonatal intensive care if the
awardees could join us on stage and all
of you join me in congratulating this
year's Donna dear speaking of nursing
the ordinary
and all of the awardees are going to
receive a copy of speaking of Nursing
which is the book that we discussed
today
we are going to have refreshments
upstairs and I would like you all to
take that opportunity to talk to the
award recipients about their work thank
you